à paris c'est un premier rassemblement
est lui à bercy en début d'après midi un
cortège quant à lui composé de
professionnels de la santé est arrivé
chez à l'hôpital cochin dans le 14e
arrondissement de la capitale
on retrouve tout de suite notre reporter
estelle farges estelle je le disais vous
êtes donc arrivés aux abords de
l'hôpital cochin vous êtes entourés de
plusieurs professionnels de la santé
dans quel état d'esprit sutil
eh bien il ya de la colère serre mais
aussi de l'usure c'est ce que nous ont
confié à ces professionnels de la santé
à qui nous avons pu parler de l'usure
car malgré à le ségur de la santé et le
plan du gouvernement pour l'hôpital ils
estiment ne pas avoir été entendu sur le
volet financier par exemple il souhaite
que l'augmentation à 283 euros annoncé
par le gouvernement soit étendue à tous
les postes du secteur ils réclament
aussi l'arrêt des fermetures de lits et
puis un recrutement massif plus
généralement et c'est un point que tous
ceux à qui nous avons parlé ont évoqué
ici
il souhaite il faut selon lui redonner
de l'attractivité aux secteurs je vous
propose de les écouter oui à la colère
parce qu'en fait elle est décideur
finalement on tend quand une autre
message à mes n'ont pas fait appel aux
bonnes personnes c'est à dire que les
personnes qui sont consultés
actuellement c'est les gens n'y a pas de
mixité au niveau du genre
actuellement le profil du médecin c'est
une femme jeune et c'est absolument pas
le cas dans les les conseillers des
gouvernements on a essentiellement des
hommes proches de la retraite voire déjà
quasiment la jument en âge d'être
traités donc c'est pas des gens qui vont
porter la médecine de demain c'est pas
des gens qui peuvent porter les valeurs
actuelles et c'est surtout des gens qui
sont complètement déconnectés du terrain
qui ne font plus de garde juste
suffisamment gare pour prétendre avoir
une légitimité mais c'est généralement
pas le cas nous sommes là aujourd'hui en
forme pour notamment revendiqué la
nécessité d' emploi d' emplois publics
mais aussi d'emplois dans nos
établissements du sanitaire et du
médico-social à l'hôpital nos
établissements vont très mal malgré le
ségur de la santé qui n'a pas réglé la
question en tout cas de d'emploi et de
formation
nous trouvons nous nous retrouvons après
un an d'aidé mis dans une situation
quand même catastrophique puisque les
professionnels sont épuisés et n'arrive
pas prendre leurs jours de congé et le
repos et encore beaucoup de choses à
faire sur le temps de travail des
médecins sur le permanent des soins
sur les carrières intermédiaires qui
n'ont pas été évaluées serait mauvais
sort côté pour au cours de
du ségur et les fermetures de lui le
budget de l'hôpital le financement de
l'hôpital qui est largement insuffisant
pour son fonctionnement pour un
fonctionnement correct donc pour les
médecins pour les soignants et aussi
pour les patients parce que c'est eux
quand même le coeur du sujet voilà
pierre pour les revendications qui vous
l'aurez compris vont au delà du volet
financier du côté du portage et bien il
s'était lancé en début d'après-midi
depuis bercy pour rejoindre donc
l'hôpital cochant je me trouve le lieu
de la dispersion merci beaucoup et elle
parcourt toutes ces précisions donc en
direct de l'hôpital cochin en compagnie
de manifestants de professionnels de la
santé